Speaker 1: We start today with Donald Trump's
CNN town hall. We are going to talk about
how CNN handled it. We will talk about reaction
to the town hall from Trump supporters. We
will talk about reaction to the town hall
from Republicans and Democrats in elected
office and from other networks. But we have
to start with the town hall itself, which
was 2 hours of Trump lying uncontrollably,
calling the host Kaitlan Collins nasty and
telling the same corrosive, greatest hits
detrimental to American democracy that we
have seen him tell for years now with some
pushback from Kaitlan Collins. But a structure
that was completely unprepared for the absurdity
and insanity of the event at the very top
level, MSNBC put together this sort of highlight
list, which included Trump continuing to say
he really won 2020, saying that Jean Carroll
made up a fake story and is a whack job. Remember,
a jury found that Trump sexually assaulted
her, called the moderator Kaitlan Collins,
a nasty person, complimented Vladimir Putin,
refused to side with Ukraine in that invasion
of Ukraine by Russia, defended keeping classified
documents at Mar a Lago, pushed Republicans
to default on the U.S. debt and said he was
inclined to pardon a bunch of the January
6th rioters. We're talking about criminals.
Let's get right into it because there is just
so I can't cover even everything that was
lied about because there were so many lies.
But let's start. Trump found liable of sexual
assault the day before, and then the next
day gets a primetime. It might have been a
one hour now. I don't remember if it was one
or 2 hours. I watched it in accelerated format
after the fact, standing ovations from a sycophant
audience and Trump arguably admitting to criminality
during this event. Trump asked those classified
documents. Did you show them to anyone? And
Trump says, Not really, which I think means,
yes, he did.
Speaker 2: When it comes to your documents,
did you ever show those classified documents
to anyone?
Speaker 3: Not really. I would have the right
to. By the way, they were declassified after
that. Not that I can think of. Let me just
tell you, I have the absolute right to do
whatever I want with them.
Speaker 1: Now. Understand? Not really. Isn't?
No. And immediately saying, Not really. But
I could definitely do it if I wanted to. Sounds
like he is saying yes. Another one of the
most notable moments was when he called Kaitlan
Collins a nasty person. Now, when I do my
analysis of how this was handled, you can
simultaneously realize Kaitlan Collins tried
to do a good job. And when she pressed Trump,
he insulted her. But also the way that this
was generally handled by CNN was a disaster.
This is sort of the epitome of that. When
she actually tries to press Trump, he just
insults her.
Speaker 2: Why you held on to those documents
when you knew the federal government was seeking
them and then had given you a subpoena to
return?
Speaker 3: You ready? Are you ready? Can I
talk?
Speaker 2: Yeah. What's the matter?
Speaker 3: Can I. Do you mind?
Speaker 2: I would like for you to answer
that. Okay.
Speaker 3: It's very simple.
Speaker 2: That's why I asked it.
Speaker 3: It's very simple that you are nasty,
personal to.
Speaker 2: Can you answer why It very high.
Speaker 3: You held on to it.
Speaker 1: And of course, the sycophant crowd
cheers. I think about this. This event embodies
the downfall of journalism, but in more than
one way, it's the downfall of journalism in
that CNN was in way over its head and completely
unprepared structurally, to handle the uncontrollable
lies flowing out of Trump's mouth like projectile
vomiting. They were unprepared to do that.
That's a problem in journalism. But also it's
the continued attacks on journalism where
when you attack the moderator who's doing
their job or trying to, your supporters cheer,
we trump insulting the person, asking questions,
really sad on many, many levels. The topics
came up related to the 2020 election. And
Kaitlan Collins, again, she's trying tries
to confront Trump with the reality that the
things he's saying, even Republicans say aren't
true about the 2020 election. And he just
steamrolls right past.
Speaker 3: Never had a paper before. Nobody
can afford to continue to pay what's happening
with energy. But we were energy independent.
We were getting out of Afghanistan with strength
and with dignity. And instead we got out.
We looked like fools. Probably the most distressing
moment in the history of our country.
Speaker 2: We have a lot of questions about
the economy and foreign policy tonight. But
what you just said there, Republican officials
debunked those claims about fraudulent ballots.
We want to give you a chance tonight who Republican
officials in Georgia and every single state.
There is no your own election officials, Mr.
President. So we want you.
Speaker 3: To take on the issue. But we have
a big problem in this country. We have we
want elections. We have elections that were
horrible. If you look at what happened in
Pennsylvania, Philadelphia, if you look at
what happened in Detroit, Michigan.
Speaker 1: This is all debunked lies.
Speaker 3: Understand that if you look at
what happened in Atlanta, millions of votes
and all you have to do is take a look at government
cameras. You'll see them people going to 28
different voting booths to vote to put in
seven ballots apiece. And they're all I can.
Speaker 2: Stop you there. That none.
Speaker 1: Of that.
Speaker 2: Happened because because there
is no evidence that your own election officials
testified to that and have said that Republicans
in these states did this. In Georgia, there
were multiple recounts, including a hand recount.
We have questions about the claims that you're
making tonight from voters on this topic.
I want to bring in Scott Dustin from Concord.
He works.
Speaker 1: All right. And then this guy, we're
not going to play it, but this guy then asked
if Trump is going to stop all of this stuff
about 2020. And Trump basically responded,
Well, if there's no more fraud, then I'll
stop talking about them. The topic of documents
did come back up. Donald Trump claimed Obama
took documents as well. Obama and Kaitlan
Collins says Obama did not take documents.
Speaker 3: Jack is not criminal. I took the
documents. I'm allowed to. You know who else
took them? Obama took them. Nixon took them
about. Reagan took argument. He did.
Speaker 2: The difference here is that I,
like Reagan, says the president.
Speaker 3: Even Jimmy Carter, even Mike Pence
had some documents. And he's a very honorable
guy.
Speaker 2: You referenced.
Speaker 3: You know, who took them more than
anybody is Joe Biden. He has 1800 boxes and
nobody even knows when you know the 1800 and
nobody talks about him.
Speaker 1: Now, these are all lies. And again,
Kaitlan Collins is trying Trump is totally
steamrolling her in absolutely every way here.
They then bring up the insurrection, the riots.
January six, 2021 Trump says Nancy Pelosi
is to Blame. Kaitlan Collins tries to interject
about Trump's continued lies about 10,000
National Guard troops, soldiers, etc. And
Trump just keeps going and going and going.
Oh, boy. Looks like we have a bit of a glitch
here with this clip, but let's see if we can
fix it for everybody.
Speaker 3: Here we go. We can go sentence
after sentence after sentence of things I
said and things I put out. One of the big
problems was that Nancy Pelosi crazy. Nancy,
as I affectionately call the crazy Nancy Pelosi
and the mayor of Washington, were in charge,
as you know, of security, and they do not
enjoy their job.
Speaker 2: GUARD You're in charge that they
are.
Speaker 3: Well, I offered them National Guard.
I said, we'll give you soldiers. We'll give
you a National Guard.
Speaker 1: Trump did not offer. Trump asked
for soldiers to protect him. That's the incredible
thing. It's it's an unbelievable, complete
rewriting of history, blaming people whose
responsibility is not what Trump claims is
their responsibility. And then we find out
Trump was worried about his own safety. He
wanted soldiers there to protect him.
Speaker 3: View whatever you want. And they
turned me down. Why? She told me very she
to excuse me. She turned me down in writing.
They turned me down.
Speaker 2: So you're acting Defense Secretary
Chris Miller at the time. He says you never
gave a formal order to to deploy the National
Guard. But when? Excuse me.
Speaker 3: Just the opposite, he said. Miller
wrote a book and he's a fantastic guy and
he was ready to go. They turned him down.
Speaker 1: These are all lies. And then maybe
one of the most horrifying aspects to this
and again. With a sycophant crowd like this.
If the crowd's cheering, that's a moment you
want to zoom in on, because Trump's probably
saying something horrible. And indeed, Donald
Trump says he will pardon a large number of
the alleged insurrectionists and convicted
insurrectionists.
Speaker 3: And what they've done and I love
that question because what they've done to
so many people is nothing, nothing. And then
what they've done to these people, they've
persecuted these people. And, you know, my
my answer is I am most likely if I get in,
I will most likely I will say it will be a
large portion of them. You know, they did
a very.
Speaker 1: If the crowd's cheering, it's probably
a really bad moment. And that alone Trump
saying I am going to mass pardon criminals
who were rioting on my behalf. Put everything
else aside. Put the rest of the town hall,
put everything aside. That alone is a great
reason not to vote for Donald Trump. When
Kaitlan Collins brings up Mike Pence. Mike
Pence, Trump's former vice president, says,
Trump endangered my life that day with what
he did and what he incited. Will you apologize?
And Trump says, I don't really think I didn't.
He did some Pence did something wrong by not
holding up the certification of Joe Biden's.
Speaker 2: Person who was at the Capitol that
day, as you know, was your vice president,
Mike Pence, who says that you endangered his
life on that day.
Speaker 3: I don't think he was in any danger.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, do you feel that
you owe him an apology?
Speaker 3: No, because he did something wrong.
He should have put the votes back to the state
legislatures. And I think we would have had
a different outcome. I really do.
Speaker 1: The crowds cheering when the crowd
cheered, it was a signal that this is one
of the crazier things that Donald Trump is
saying. Of course, Mike Pence did not have
the authority or ability or right or permission
to call it whatever you want. He did not have
the ability to reject the election of Joe
Biden and to somehow try to stuff Trump into
the Oval Office for four more years. Then
the topic of Jean Carroll came up. Now, I
want you to remember that the day before this
town hall, a jury found Trump liable civilly
for the sexual assault and defamation of Jean
Carroll for Trump's assault on her in the
1990s in a Bergdorf Goodman Department store
in Manhattan. Trump brings up that Jean Carroll
had a pet named Vagina and that the judge
wouldn't let that be part of the trial. I'm
not kidding, folks. It's 2023, former president
running again. This is what he's talking about.
Speaker 3: A dog or her cat was named vagina.
The judge wouldn't allow to put that in all
of these things. He would. But with her, they
can put in anything, access to a.
Speaker 2: Jury of nine people who found you
liable of sexual abuse. Do you think that
that will deter women from voting for you?
No, I.
Speaker 3: Don't think so, because I think
the whole thing just so you understand, really.
I never met this woman. I never saw this woman.
Speaker 1: He never saw her. I don't believe
a word he's saying. And then Trump actually
goes into a detailed story about the circumstances.
I think it just lost the light in my suit.
That was weird. Goes into a detailed. So we'll
get that fixed up. He tells a story about
what's being said happened, and it's one of
the most bizarre moments of the entire thing.
Speaker 3: I never met this woman. I never
saw this woman. This woman said. I met her
at the front door of Bergdorf Goodman, which
I rarely go into, other than for a couple
of charities. I met her in the front door.
She was about 60 years old, and this is like
20 to 23 years ago.
Speaker 1: She was 52.
Speaker 3: I met her in the front door of
Bergdorf Goodman. I was immediately attracted
to her and she was immediately attracted to
me. And we had this great chemistry. We're
walking into a crowded department store. We
had this great chemistry, and a few minutes
later we end up in a a room, a dressing room,
a Bergdorf Goodman right near the gym.
Speaker 1: The crowd laughs and laughs and
laughs. They just love it. Remember, Trump's
been found civilly liable for sexual assault
and they're just making fun of the victim.
The crowd's loving it. Everybody's having
a party to register.
Speaker 3: And then she found out there are
locks on the door. So she said, I found one
that was open. She found one. She learned
this at trial. She found one that was open.
What kind of a woman meet somebody and brings
them up and within minutes you're playing
Hankie Panky in a dressing room. Okay. I don't
know if she was married then or not. John
Johnson. I feel sorry for you, John.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, can I.
Speaker 1: So think of it. An entire crowd
on national TV led by Trump, disgustingly
laughing about the sexual assault that remember,
it's not a mere allegation now. A jury found
Trump liable for that and the crowd just having
a grand old time. Kaitlan Collins did ask
Trump about the infamous Access Hollywood
tape where Trump says you can just grab women
by the you know what? Trump Trump defends
it, says there's nothing wrong because he
says they let you do it. They let you do it.
Speaker 2: There was a tape deposition of
you from October and it you defended the comments
that you made on that Access Hollywood tape
about being able to grab women how you want.
Do you stand by those comments?
Speaker 3: I said if you're famous and rich
or whatever I said, but I said of your star,
you are. And I said, women let you. I didn't
say you grew up. I said, Women let you know
you didn't use that word. But if you look,
women let you Now they said, Will you take
that back? I said, Look, for a million years.
This is the way it's been. I want to be honest.
That's the way it's been. I can take it back
if you'd like to. But if you're a famous person,
if you're a star and I'm not referring to
myself, I'm saying people that are famous,
people that are you.
Speaker 2: In a deposition.
Speaker 3: People that.
Speaker 2: Are rich.
Speaker 3: People that are powerful, they
tend to do pretty well in a lot of different
ways. Okay. And you would like me to take
that back? I can't take it back because it
happens to be true. I said it's been true
for 1 million years.
Speaker 1: A million years, even before Homo
sapiens. It was absolutely the truth. Trump
then moving on to what we might call foreign
policy, the idea of Trump foreign policy.
I know it's kind of laughable, but given a
number of opportunities to say, you know,
given that Russia invaded Ukraine and Russia
is in the wrong, do you want Ukraine to come
out victorious from that or do you want Russia
to successfully take over Ukraine? Trump refused
to answer that question.
Speaker 2: Nancy Pelosi said here is would
you give Ukraine weapons and funding?
Speaker 3: If you were, I would sit down.
Let me just put it this way. If I'm president,
I will have that war settled in one day, 24
hours. How would you.
Speaker 1: Settle? And again, the crowd's
cheering, so it must be Trump said something
stupid. And indeed, how on earth are you going
to settle that in 24 hours or so?
Speaker 3: Meet with the landscape. They both
have weaknesses and they both have strengths.
And within 24 hours, that war will be settled.
It'll be over. It'll be absolutely.
Speaker 2: Ukraine to win this war.
Speaker 3: I don't think in terms of winning
and losing. I think in terms of getting it
settled. So we stop killing all these people
and breaking them.
Speaker 1: Oh, sounds like a sort of both
sides perspective on something Russia did
here. That's. And the crowd loves it. And
I just.
Speaker 3: Follow up on that. You said you
don't think you have to do things. You have
to get. You have to.
Speaker 2: Follow up on that because that's
a really.
Speaker 3: She's me. Let me just me there.
Speaker 2: Can you say if you want Ukraine
or Russia to win this war?
Speaker 3: I want everybody to stop dying.
They're dying.
Speaker 1: Russians and Ukrainians dying like
dogs. So he refused to answer that, refused
to answer that. And then lastly, and not surprisingly,
the cherry on top, Trump refuses to commit
to accepting the results of the 2024 election.
Speaker 2: Are you? You are running in the
2024 race. If you are the Republican nominee
and you were in that 2024 race. Will you commit
tonight to accepting the results of the 2024
election?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think it's an honest election,
absolutely.
Speaker 1: That means no to accepting the
results of the election.
Speaker 3: Regardless of the outcome. Foreman
answered again, If I think it's an honest
election, I would be honored to. And right
now, we are so far ahead of both Democrat
and Republican. And you know what? If I don't
win, this country is going to be in big trouble.
It's so sad to see what's happened, but no
commitment there. On the accepting the results,
regardless of the outcome, if it's an honest
election, Correct?
Speaker 2: Okay. So not committing to accepting
the 2024 election results.
Speaker 1: Oregon and Trump just kind of waves
off Kaitlan Collins in the crowd laughs And
everybody has a grand old time. This is dangerous.
Everybody's laughing off the fact that he
did it in 2020 and he's saying he's going
to do it again in 2024. If he loses, he will
say that it was rigged. Disastrous event for
democracy. Let's now talk about CNN's role
in this